psychological scars I can I can't do my
dad knows myself but what I can tell you
is that when you are sharing the common
humanity with others you can't be
indifferent and this can touch you in
different way because I'm I'm husband I
have a mother I have doctors and I have
grandchildren and my question is most of
the time how can I cop this if it
happened in my own family it's terrible
and you can't stop to think about it
because it just make women to suffer
without any reason someone actually I
mean you're obviously an enemy for many
as for these rapists and these people
trying to do so much damage and and and
two years ago someone actually tried to
kill you yes five people with guns they
come at my place I just find that my two
daughters was abducted by these people
and they take place in my house or they
were waiting waiting for me and one of
my stuff he was there and he he
understood that they they just want to
kill me and he tried to just to save me
I can say and they start to shoot and it
was sad because they shot on him and he
died he died directly and I've I felt
down and I I just I can't explain how
today I'm alive because they should ever
wear and for them when they saw just two
bodies on on the floor they think that I
was also dead and the blood was
everywhere
so but after I saw that I was not
wounded and it was just something that I
can't explain but I'm so sorry for Jeff
my staff who who died this day how can
you still work you you you you're in in
the hospital how can you keep safe yes
today my life changed completely because
now I'm walking in the hospital and I'm
living in the hospital for my safety and
I think that it's a it's a question of
etic how could I just give up when in
the hospital there was a thousand of
women who were waiting for me and when I
was in in Belgium because I took
decision that I don't want to stay in
this country because I have done my best
but nothing happened nothing change and
the women start just to protest they
wrote letter to the President of Congo
they wrote a letter to the Secretary
General of the UN and they wrote many
letter to protest and they organized
even the demonstration in the town to
ask our authorities to bring me back in
Congo so I think that in this condition
I was so touched by these strength of
women to to protest and to asked me to
come back and when they saw that I was
not reacting either as a demand they
start to sell fruit to pay my ticket and
there I was not in a need of the ticket
but their eyes I just said I'm not more
values on them so I have just go back
and today we are living together in the
hospital I am NOT patient but we are
like a community with patient and
threatened
we today we sit here very comfortable in
safety and in a very different
environment than your daily environment
what what can we do I think that Nordic
countries they have a big experience in
peace building and this consolidation
and to be here for me this even is
really to try to get your voice and I'm
thankful for inviting me because I know
that all the Nordic countries will
follow this show and what we are asking
them is a voice to give their voice to
women of Congo they need your voice and
it's only one way we can bring policy
makers to to make the change in what is
going on in Congo it is not a fight
between types it's not a fight
religion fight between two religion it's
not a fight between countries it's
justified for to get the control of
mineral and this mineral is used by all
of us so it's not soft culturally you
know it's about money it's about money
so I think that all of us can can just
help to stop this kind of of things I
think that it's immoral what is going on
in Congo what what do you say what are
you thinking when you live every story I
think it's just awful I've heard of this
before and it's I don't know how is it
getting better as it getting worse
are they having any kind of support is
there safe places for women to be is it
always war as it as there always
conflict at this time is it I'm trying
to figure out how I can help how I can
what I can do what anybody can do so
many would be very depressive day they
work I mean would do you ever see happy
endings yes I think that happiness we
have some time
we're really we feel that we have a
reason to be there because when you can
get a women who are completely destroyed
I have seen women of 30 years with only
25 30 kilogram because she was slaves in
the bush and come with a fistula who is
a communication between the bladder and
genital or the rectum and the janitor
and you have just impression that she
come to the hospital to to die but when
they can got healing and come to you
just for to show you that there are able
to urinate again it it's just two born
again and when this happened really I
can says and this is giving me a hope
and happiness in what I'm doing and it
is one of the reason to be there and
then it's McRea it's it's been said many
times that you are a nominee for the
Nobel Peace Prize III can understand
that very well I congratulate you with
the soccer of Christ this week and
I wish you best of luck with your very
important work and thank you so much for
coming here tonight welcome welcome to
Scandinavia thank you and first of all
congratulations with the Sakura price
you you you